could have a huge impact here on  southern nevada the oakland aids and  oakland city leaders are meeting  tomorrow morning  to discuss a term sheet for the club  major league baseball wants a team out  of the coliseum  and the proposal is a 12 billion dollar  plan that includes everything from a  stadium to low-income housing  the team says both sides are about 500  million apart  if the two sides can't come together  look for the a's  to las vegas proposition to really gain  some traction  we will be following that meeting very  closely tomorrow we'll have live reports  from the bay area  the president of the years or others  says that the back and forth with the  city is now  in the ninth inning guys